have you ever encountered a patient
perhaps that maybe in psychological
settings well there could be but I think
there's a bigger problem with free will
which is that if you say something and I
say something somebody looks at my brain
at the activity recording or processing
what you said I will have already
responded to you or a baseball player
actually swings the bat and doesn't
really have enough time to know where
the ball is and going back to the
experiments of Benjamin libbit 1979 he
found that the brain refers information
backward in time this backward time
effect enables us to act in real time so
even though the activity process hasn't
happened yet it's going backward in time
so I can answer you consciously